il s'appelle jordan florentin il se
présente comme journaliste pour la
chaîne youtube le livre noir et ils
affirment avoir été menacées séquestré
par l'humoriste yassine belattar à
l'issue de sa représentation
alors que le journaliste confie réalisé
un documentaire il aurait été retenu par
les équipes du théâtre et par yassine
belattar lui même qui lui aurait demandé
la carte mémoire de sa caméra
le sujet après son témoignage jordan
florentin aurait été retenue enfermée à
l'intérieur du bâtiment avant d'être
humilié et lynché en étant comparée à la
prochaine milla selon yassine belattar
l'homme se serait fait passer pour un
journaliste besoin de brut est de
combiner pour interroger de ses
spectateurs ou très très choquée
évidemment que racistes soient venus
hier au théâtre pour nous piéger qui
sont sur notre plateau ce soir pour
tenter de comprendre ce qu'il s'est
réellement passé
alors d'abord on va recevoir jordan
florentin pour avoir sa version des
faits vous êtes journaliste livre noir
qu'est ce qui s'est passé vendredi soir
bonsoir d'avoir merci de me recevoir ce
qui s'est passé jeudi soir dans le cadre
d'un reportage que je tournais pour
livre nantes dont je suis journaliste je
me suis rendu au théâtre de la sinne
bela tarr pour un reportage qui
s'intitulait les sénateurs est il un
homme politique blanc l'humoriste
c'était un un reportage à charge à la
base ou pas du tout à charge lui va
considérer de sa charge nous on fait ça
en toute bienveillance et avait tout
l'intégrer d'intégrité que je me dois
d'avoir autant de journalistes
maintenant c'était pas la charge voire
choisi yassine belattar pour refaire ce
sujet précisément pour les raisons que
j'ai vote est il un homme politique
d'accord il fait un spectacle ou sur
l'intégralité du spectacle il attaque
les médias la tâche des journalistes
comment son spectacle en demandant s'il
ya des blancs dans la salle pour moi ça
relève de l'opposition politique et
c'est très bien su gérer son spectacle
par comment vous avez rigolé son
spectacle bien sûr mais je pense que je
vous dis j'ai eu à sin pas réussir et il
m'a dit qu'il avait vous aviez rigoler à
son à son spectacle tout se passait bien
ça après des mauvaises volées d'accord
mais ça que j'aime rigoler parce qu'en
sortant du spectacle
vous voyez spectacle voilà vous êtes
tout seul non je suis accompagné d'un
jeune
et ils travaillent avec nous à
scheibenhard un contrat d'apprentissage
c'est après j'aimerais de l'état lorsque
nous prend par l'épaule le nom de
l'intérieur le spectacle se termine le
spectacle se termine je reste parce que
ces bâtards tente de faire enfin fait
des photos avec les personnes qui
restent d'abord on n'est pas sain quand
on a une vingtaine c'est a tué ce matin
a pas de difficulté à compter les blancs
dans ce spectacle en revanche pour
compter des personnes qui restent
présentes là dessus ils n'ont quelque
sorte puisqu'il n'est absolument pas 50
personnes il dit c'est des témoins ces
personnes c'est avant tout des fans et
des militants qui sont venus à son
spectacle quand vous dites des militants
parce que pour vous c'est un spectacle
politique laisse un spectacle politique
mais tout à fait d'ailleurs j'invite à
d'autres journalistes et même le
ministère de l'intérieur si intéressé
sur les propos qui sont tenus à
l'intérieur peuvent à mon avis relever
de la loi pour certains certains
passages ce qui se passe c'est yassine
belattar me demande de rester à
l'intérieur mais aussi à l'intérieur
fait baissé les grilles les portes sont
fermées et à ce moment là il me dit tu
es jordan sétois jordan qui a piégé les
jeunes de les sous bois c'est toi qui a
fait un reportage sur le remplacement
sache que +93 est à sa recherche sache
que tu t'es mis dans la position de
villa située la prochaine nuit là je
serais si on se rend compte de la
gravité de ses propos ça fait quarante
huit heures je reçois des menaces de
mort autant que milla dont je souligne
une nouvelle fois le courage j'ai pas vu
réaction du ministère l'intérieur j'ai
pas vu la réaction de l'elysée non c'est
le dessinateur est un proche de manuel
macro et j'ai vu de fait peu de réaction
et je vous le dis à vous tous qui êtes
présents ici tu connaissais yassine
belattar j'ai vu très peu de réactions
de mes collègues journalistes d'autres
confrères alors nous on voulait avoir
les deux versions d'été jordan je pense
que vous êtes là aussi où vous au départ
dix ou onze itou dit la vérité au départ
livre noir c'est quoi c'est plutôt à
droite plutôt bouche plutôt d'être à
droite non vivres lens est un média qui
a une ligne éditoriale et il assume ce
que peut-être d'autres médias le font
pas nous l'assumons n'a rien de
politique mais absolument pas partisan
d'accord au départ et que vous allez
voir yassine belattar c'est pas pour
faire les éloges de yacine je pense on
se dit que ça s'appelle faire du
jeunisme j'aurais sens bien que moi la
version critiques comme ça on en parle
tous les deux est ce que c'est vous avez
parlé aux spectateurs avant le spectacle
pour poser des questions sur yacine des
questions bien évidemment c'était 2003
quatre ans c'était des intervenants qui
devra abriter les tensions d'ailleurs
toute bienveillance mais comme on l'a
fait comme on peut le voir sur la chaîne
youtube de livres au nord sous le
reportage sur le remplacement c'est
toujours avec un ton différent quoi les
questions posées la gestion c'est que
pensez-vous de yassine belattar pourquoi
vous êtes venus ce soir est ce pour vous
un homme politique ou un humoriste je
pensais vous est d'ailleurs je ne
demande pas si peut être proche de
mouvance islamiste je demande ce qu'il
pense
lorsque certains l'accusent de cela la
queue c'est d'ailleurs ce pour fait je
le redis dans la vidéo sur leur
emplacement on demande passe et le
remplacement existent on demande qu'est
ce que vous les jeunes vous en pensez
d'accord alors donc jordan donc vous
allez vous vous interrogez les gens
ensuite vous voyez le spectacle
sortie du spectacle vous l'attendez pour
pour vous l'attendez on l'attendait pour
faire une photo avec lui nous est
parvenue à ce moment là d'accord donc là
il fait la photo et vous d'abord non il
ne fait pas la photo que je suis à ce
moment là que commence l'agression et
payet du monde y attend personne n'a à
peu près 20 personnes qui reste c'est
son public qui reste pour faire la photo
de twilight vous dit quoi vous dit c'est
toi tu leur donnes alors en fait le
vigile le garde du corps de décimales
atteint nous venons de sortir on
commence à s'expliquer avec lui et en
fait ça si bel attar sort le rattraper
me dit tu reviens à l'intérieur on va
s'expliquer et c'est là qu'ils
m'expliquent que j'étais rentré dans la
tanière au lion que c'était le lion
c'était lui challenge londres et puis
j'étais chez lui dans le xviiie est
urgent était suicidaire des travers son
spectacle et c'est là où commence celle
des noirs de l'enfermement ou deux fois
on est empêché de sortir d'ailleurs il
me retient même de communiquer avec
l'extérieur puisque on entendra dans
l'appel et j'espère qu'il est enregistré
des policiers du xviiie ou à deux
reprises quand je leur explique que je
n'ai pas de raison que je souhaite
sortir le alors de mémoire c'était le
garde du corps de la simat archie mais
son nom sur les portes et ils
m'empêchent de sortir théâtre pendant
une heure de 00h30 à 1h40 nous sommes
retenus à l'intérieur sans possibilité
de sortir et au delà de ça yassine
belattar me demande de retirer ma carte
sd de mon appareil photo de supprimer
des fichiers d'ocha de l'extorsion la
carte sd je n'ai pas revu je n'ai pas
revu le moyen de déplacement j'étais une
trottinette j'étais sur place et ces
fichiers sont supprimés par la force par
l'intimidation on est encerclée par dix
tierce personne et puis au delà de ça
c'est l'aspect ou yacine à terme le film
en direct moi j'ai atteint mon téléphone
j'ai jamais dis que mon téléphone avait
été pris j'ai atteint mon téléphone
j'essaye de contre filmé mais après
après que j'ai sorti mon téléphone toute
son équipe nous demande de vider mes
fichiers et et là où pour moi je le sent
doublement victime c'est d'une part il
ya ce que j'ai vécu et je souhaite
vraiment à personne ne sait sauf plateau
de vivre cette situation parce que ya
pas de l'aspect de la violence
psychologique de ce que j'ai vécu hier
soir il ya tout ce qu'on reçoit après et
on pense à ses proches sur ce moment là
on se dit je peux pas devenir la
nouvelle villa parce que j'ai un métier
à défendre j'ai des confrères qui
veulent qu'on continue lui aussi qui
sont parfois dans cette situation et
puis il ya une la deuxième chose c'est
l'intimidation l'humiliation que je vis
après parce que forcément je peux
entendre qu'on me dise que ma version
n'est pas crédible puisque moi je ne
dispose de plus rien mais c'est la
technique belattar en fait c'est à dire
on vous fait faire des choses il appelle
la police parce qu'il a besoin de se
protéger et puis me fait supprimer
toutes mes proches toutes les preuves
pardon alors l'idée il a beaucoup plus
d'impact que moi on vous attend vous
avons pour vous donner sa version
évidemment que moi je suis je peux
absolument rien faire face à lui alors
il dit qu'à un moment
il vous lui dites est ce que tu crois
que les gens vont croire toi ou moi oui
ça y paraît que j'ai absolument pas pas
le souvenir d'avoir du style vraiment
ouais j'ai absolument telle somme nadal
andy cela vous avez revanche j'ai
souvenir de lui avoir demandé s'il se
rendait compte de ce qu'il est en train
de faire à savoir de séquestrer des
journalistes sur la croix il m'a répondu
enfin pas que je ne devais pas être des
fachos moi je vais proposer de débattre
savez j'étais prêt à accepter de
débattre avec lui ce soir mais ce qui
s'est passé et je tiens à le dire a
voulu cette volvo laboratoire en entrant
on fait comprendre qu'il fallait
absolument pas que je croise des
simulateurs dans sa loge le contenu du
jeu plus étanche et de sylvain arrivé en
sortant vous étiez ce qui va m'arriver
danger vous étiez prêts jordan à
débattre avec yacine boussois mais
j'étais prêt à débattre avec yassine
belattar mais savait bon bah on valoir
vraiment là on va demander à signer là
où
jt pendant deux jours et horaires vous
savez quand on est sûr de soi quand on a
rien à se reprocher quand c'est ce qu'on
est on n'a pas besoin de sauter forme
d'accord alors vous invitez vous savez
on dit vous avez été traumatisée par ce
qui s'est passé deux versions mais je
suis sentie vous savez mes proches
connaissent mon courage je suis sorti je
tremblais j'ai appelé mon talent de quoi
j'ai eu peur d'être d'abord vraiment y
pensiez vraiment oui mais en fait c'est
pas seulement je le pensais 7 si tenté
qu'il ya eu des caméras avec les bandes
n'est pas été supprimés dans la gueule
du théâtre on verra qu'il a à plusieurs
reprises tenté de frapper au visage moi
je sors de là je d'abord je ne comprends
même pas ce qui s'est passé et sur le
moment je ne réalise même pas en fait je
supprime des preuves en fait d'accord
mais lui semblant yacine yacine gemmayzé
qui brouillent tournée en direct un don
qui communique avec moi qui me lisent le
rédacteur en chef me dit dans l'émission
qu'il est avec yacine et qui a une
plainte en cours donc il veut pas
débattre avec vous ce qu'il a porté
plainte contre vous rassure également un
mais bien sûr vous avez porté plainte de
vos six alors moi j'ai porté plainte lui
tu as porté plainte récemment il a
déposé une main courante imagine que si
j'avais vraiment fait des choses graves
il aurait porté plainte directement sur
déposé une main courante pas en revanche
il a fait des story est haram où il me
dit femme gravement il expliqué et c'est
là moi ce qui me sidère le plus c'est
que j'explique que je me suis fait
passer pour un journaliste de brut ou de
combiner alors c'est vrai alors ça c'est
vrai ça c'est la bonette de livres noirs
c'est celle que je n'ai absolument pas
eu peur de porter sur mon micro en
allant dans la cité des 3000 années sur
la vieillesse in je l'avais chelsea mais
là tard je la verrai site d'aulnay sous
bois où le menton son vélo dire je suis
de livres noirs et je viens vous n'avez
pas dit que vous étiez de bruit n'ont
pas épargné au spectateur mais il y
aussi les hauteurs de yassine belattar
avec ma bonne est si je suis allé dans
des cités avec cette graine de l'ivraie
mois contrairement à lui je pense être
fier de ce que je fais lui je pense que
si tout le monde savait ce qui se dira
son spectacle la violence contre les
médias de traiter natacha polony et
zineb el rhazoui je le dis de [ __ ] du
pf de traiter rythme le nazi si tout le
monde savait ce qui se dira ce spectacle
je pense pas qu'ils pourraient être fier
de ce qu'il a fait moi je suis très fier
de mon métier
aujourd'hui donc c'est à vous êtes allés
au spectacle quand vous êtes allés au
spectacle une porte vous ne portiez pas
dans votre coeur déjà vous savez moi je
ressens que de haine envers personne la
haine c'est la haine c'est une forme de
passion j'ajoute une passion pour lui
même s'il faudrait d'abord qu'il ne
m'intéresse pas il vous intéresse
puisque vous avez conseillé m'intéresse
pour mon métier mais m'intéresse pas à
titre personnel d'intérêt je sais par
totalement lui c'est vous qui avez
choisi ce sujet oui c'est moi qui
choisis ça se fait dans tous les médias
pourquoi est elle si je vous ai dit ça
va mal ça va marcher ça va faire parler
ou pas du tout mais évidemment vous êtes
journaliste en moi vous savez moi vous
êtes journaliste me suis rien
bon moi
je rien du tout mais c'est vrai que j'ai
pas journaliste noir vous vous êtes
journaliste mais c'est vrai que vous
choisissez le sujet vous êtes dit ça
peut faire un bon sujet parce que yacine
c'est quelqu'un qui va faire on se dit
qu'il va faire buzz et qui va faire ou
pas du tout mais vous savez en tout cas
j'aurais préféré faire mon premier
plateau tv pour autre chose que cette
affaire je m'expose ce soir j'ai choisi
ma famille j'expose mes proches vous
avez reçu des menaces de mort oui j'ai
reçu des menaces de mort face et ça sert
à ça je le dis que ce soit chez un psy
je suis le genre de match c'est
inadmissible arrêtez avec ça et j'espère
qu'il recevra pas non mais il en a reçu
aussi c'est ce qui m'a dit que je
l'aimais mais je vous le dis il a reçu
voilà même concernant il ya même des
gens qui vise sur ce plateau on va
t'attaquer ce soir sur le plateau de là
nous n'avons direct voilà et
jordan tout ce qui vous dit ça c'est le
meilleur moyen je vous dis les menaces
des trucs sur les réseaux pour vraiment
sortir du débat mais je vous dis cc
c'est pas du tout ce qu'il faut faire
voilà je préfère deux personnes qui
discutent voilà qui se disent des choses
et qui repartent ne peut être du bon
pied que peut-être que jordan va dire
bah écoutes je me suis trompé sur yacine
peut-être qui sait il s'est énervé parce
qu'il a cru quelque chose et qui est
voilà moi je n'avais rien contre lui
quand je suis arrivé moi je suis sûr
jours pour le dialogue j'aurais préféré
vous dialoguez soit vous allez donner
chacun votre version mais moi cette
histoire me rend triste pour les deux
parce que je vous lis voilà je serai
qu'à six mois je le connais ici il fait
des chroniques que ça se passe très bien
et c'est quelqu'un qui est très
sympathique voilà et avec qui on rigole
énormément vous j'ai rien contre vous
forcément voilà je je me dis et je me
dis c'est aussi ses choix je me dis
c'est peut-être partie aussi d'une
psychose et les gens sont montés à 6000
sont dit voilà ce mec là devant du mal
je pense qu'il ya aussi après il va
donner sa version mais
aujourd'hui je vous ai vu aussi chez
jean-marc ce matin vous savez lire
vraiment
j'ai l'impression que c'est c'est un
truc qui va marquer votre votre carrière
évidemment j'aurais préféré la démarrer
autrement c'est la première fois que
vous faites c'est depuis combien de
temps moi je fais ça depuis deux mois
moi d'accord c'est très récent mois
avant j'étais les collaborateurs
politiques d'accord avec qui j'ai
travaillé notamment la mairie du 17e km
ce matin j'étais j'étais inquiet j'avais
peur et ce soir je suis désemparé je
suis désemparée de voir qu uniquement
des confrères de marianne valeurs
actuelles m'ont apporté leur soutien
mais tu doutes se sont tus pourtant il
si vous toussez hassan belattar je pense
que vous connaissez tous ces techniques
vous connaissez la violence qui peut
avoir en privé
mais nous alors vraiment le jour n'a pas
été le tournage toujours rire avec avec
moi ça se passe toujours très bien avec
l'egypte est toujours oui je l'avais
dans mes shows l'y ai vraiment aimé
ville a eu un problème et qu'eric
naulleau on en a parlé sur ce plateau
mais c'est vrai que ici avec avec les
autres équipes je dis voilà ça ça se
fasse ça se passe ça se passe plutôt
bien après voilà là même le dire on n'a
jamais eu de violence voilà qui annula
tard j'avais un amant yacine il avait un
ton très bien avec un jeune philippe
gille dans leurs amis on s'entend très
bien oui moi j'ai une question à vous
analysiez à jour donne vous avez parlé
deux fois de la technique belattar
escape à une technique livre noir
technique livre noir d'aller là-bas de
chercher la séquence entre guillemets
moi c'est ce qu'on m'a dit mais voilà de
se payer bela tarr pour vous faire
connaître augmenter votre audience
est-ce que vous alliez pas là bas avec
vraiment une idée préconçue je vais vous
poser la question inverse ce que la tête
n'utilise lui c'est la technique
quotidien vous gêne ou vous gêne depuis
longtemps tous les médias font ça tous
les médias font ça on utilise des
méthodes sur les méthodes
journalistiques mais mais mais en
revanche jordan ou avec châtaignes et et
bienveillance nommé jon je comprends
tout à fait mais c'est vrai que cette
technique peut agacer quelques fois on
le voit mois voilà l issue si j'aime
beaucoup préfet aux côtes il ya aussi un
je crois qu'ils n'ont très bon boulot
j'étais censé maintenant je me suis pas
caché voilà non mais non mais après
c'est vrai qu'il ya des gens qui se
sentent agressés joue dur et j'ai vu
plusieurs confrères plusieurs amis qui
m'ont dit je me suis sentie agressée par
continent je me suis sentie agressée par
élise lucet on l'a vu ce qui s'est passé
avec francis lalanne qu'il n'y en ait
pas un mal acquis lui aussi qui lui
aussi ben voilà ce n'est pas facile mais
voilà il est là pour poser des questions
est exactement oui mais des questions
oui oui mais attention attention
attention il est là pour poser des
questions mais mais mais ce que
j'aime ici donc on travaille j'ai c'est
un bulletin tai chi minh hoang quan a vs
qui est reprochée c'est que les ce qui
vous est reproché je vous dis jordan je
te dit tout on se tutoie alors là c'est
tu parlais des us et deux quotidiens
quotidien ce qui leur à skis lors
souvent elles sont reprochés c'est que
il
ils viennent pour un sujet en fait ils
en font un autre il coupe il recoupe
derrière ça c'est ça qui est gênant et
que les gens et les gens disent à un
moment on leur parle plus on leur dit un
truc et quand arrive à l'antenne c'est
autre chose pardon ce que vous dites sur
le coupage c'est très intéressant
vraiment aller regarder la vidéo sur
leur emplacement sur youtube sur la
chaîne livre noir il ya 52 minutes nous
n'avons réalisé aucun montage ce qui est
effarant c'est yassine belattar en plus
de ceux qui n'osent espérer quand elles
payer les jeunes font interviewer
n'explique que j'ai piéger ces jeunes
qu'ils nous disent face caméra et rythme
on va lui couper la tête vous pensez
sincèrement j'aurais été en mesure de
demander un jeune de me dire ça face
caméra pensez sincèrement cela vous
allez dis quoi au commissariat bajeux
raconté les faits comme un corps et vous
où on dit quoi d'abord ils ont vu
puisque les policiers de 18 ans dispense
alors il paraît que c'est yacine qui a
pas à capter les policiers bien sûr non
mais les appels pour se protéger il les
a appelés pour se sécuriser je les
appelais de mon côté malheureusement moi
je n'ai pas pu sortir et être avoir du
réseau pour les journalistes
ils vous ont dit que la police est
arrivée ils ont dû mettre ya simulateur
de côté qui m'a traitée de belles train
de devant les policiers cela fera partie
du rapport des policiers les policiers
mais même escortée à l'extérieur pour me
faire prendre un taxi me rassure sur sur
mon état certes il est resté violent
même de voir les policiers c'est à dire
que cet homme n'a moi ce que j'ai sorti
c'est de cet homme n'avait aucune limite
certes le même devant des agents forces
de l'ordre dont je remercie vraiment la
curie parce que nous ont soutenus
derrière parce qu'ils ont vu la violence
mais ce qui se passait et moi je peux
miser uniquement sur start et filles et
des caméras à l'accueil chameyrat but
d'assurance dans la rue tu montreras de
la grille a été baissé et sur le rapport
des agents pour me défendre qu'est ce
que vous dites aux langues qui disent
qu'il y avait tendu un piège
d'abord tous ceux qui étaient présents
qui visiblement se sont manifestés
s'adresse-t-il bela tarr pour donner
leurs témoignages qui vient nous donner
le loiret pour n'en discute j'étais prêt
à discuter chelsea belattar ce soir je
suis prêt à disputer un match où vous
étiez prêt à discuter avec mes samedis
soirs mais j'étais prêt à discuter un
livre dire toi samedi soir qu'on vous
l'avez rencontrée mais je si j'avais eu
la capacité de l'interviewer j'aurais
posé les questions juridiques
l'association spectacle made man
j'aurais dit cats personnel j'avais pu
être jugé par certains trop tôt j'aurais
dit que j'avais pu rire à certains
moments mais je leur ai interviewé avec
londres le nouveau partage à savoir si
lui quand il fait son spectacle il a
l'impression de faire un show politique
ou un show humoristique serait sur la
ligne lyon nom vous dit que le spectacle
de yassine belattar c'est un spectacle
politique mais ce que vous oubliez dire
c'est que vous êtes un média politiques
livrent aux nantais dit clairement non
mais c'est clairement un média d'extrême
droite il faut le dire vous faites des
portrait à l'extrême droite pour vous
vous faites des portraits à la gloire
que j'ai regardé un dauphin philippot
d'eric zemmour de longs entretiens qui
sont plutôt très bienveillants envers
eux et j'ai l'impression moi c'est une
impression que vous utilisez certes une
altercation musclée mais vous
l'extrapoler en utilisant des termes
très violents comme séquestration
agression traumatisme pour à la fois
faire la promotion de votre média parce
que depuis cette agression vous êtes
partout dans les médias vous avez sorti
une vidéo immédiatement après
l'altercation est aussi alimenté un
climat malheureusement qui règne un
climat anti musulmans en france voilà ce
que vous dites c'est véritablement ce
que je craignais en venant sur ce
plateau ces luminaires sans que vous ne
pas l'être en plus super pensais que je
me serai disposé de la sorte y avaient
pu blesser doit laisser parler jordan
s'il vous plaît oui j'avoue dit c'est
violent d'abord parce que j'en ai fait
notre média et des trannois nasa et
lestrem barça se définit par la présence
de groupuscules au sein des mouvements
il ya aucun mouvement de droite en
france il ya des groupuscules violents
alors qu'il y en a à gogo chaque et
black blocks à droite ça n'existe pas
deuxièmement vous ne dit que j'étais là
il n'en attendez vous rigolez il y en a
trop d'extrême droite qui sont violées
sont des
représentations il ya plein simulator se
présentent dans ce qu'il dit à son
spectacle et sous présidence n est qu on
va laisser faire
on est 500 signatures la partie mais
juste une question est ce que vous
pouvez concevoir que l'artiste ou n'ai
pas envie de répondre aux questions d'un
média parce qu'ils parce que ça
correspond pas du tout soit assez pensé
à ce qu'ils pensent et surtout c'est
vrai que honnêtement le livre non j'ai
fait comme comme diouf j'ai été voir
votre votre blog là sur la chaîne sur
youtube ces voix là vous faites les
faits qui font l'apologie des gens qui
sont plutôt de droite et d'extrême en
témoignant après année fait ce qu'il
veut
refuser de reparler
mais fait ce qu'il veut sur son blog
si on en croit la version c'est monsieur
on verra ce que dit yacine mais refusé
de parler moi j'suis d'accord avec toi
je veux dire à un journaliste écoutez
j'ai pas envie de voir
si la version de ce monsieur est réel
c'est un problème parce que qu'on soit
d'accord ou pas avec le média qui vous
interroge on peut simplement lui dire
merci fin de non-recevoir au revoir
monsieur on le raccompagne gentiment à
la porte mais on le sait mais l'enfer
ici
à
18 heures diffusé nous avons reçu juan
branco cambadélis ne semble pas que ce
soit des personnalités de droite est
d'accord mais voilà si ensuite je n'ai
pas de maux d'estomac et l'asthme et la
terre de mardi j'ai notamment vu nos
d'accord oui votre plainte c'est
séquestration c'est extorsion et menaces
de mort mais menaces de mort contre ce
que vous avez reçues sur les réseaux
après ou contre monsieur bela tarr parce
que si c'est contre monsieur benata est
ce que vous n'allez pas un peu loin dans
ce que vous lui reprochez pour un grand
moment de tension je le conçois mais là
je trouve que séquestration extorsion
menaces de mort c'est très fort d'avoir
si vous vous trouvez par une chute on
connaît enfin le journaliste une heure
de danse au théâtre s'est joué en trois
mois je vous dis j'ai été enfermé
pendant une heure et j'ai un homme qui
me dit tout le 93 de recherche et qui
appelle je le précise deux jeunes
d'aulnay sous bois sous les yeux en
disant je tiens trop journaliste tu peux
venir moi je me demande s'il serait
passé si les policiers n'étaient pas
intervenues
yacine dit que c'est lui qui a pris aux
policiers oui mais encore une fois pour
se protéger c'est ce que je dis aux
joueurs et pour accréditer sa version il
me fait supprimer preuve il ne retire ma
carte sd je n'ai pas aujourd'hui en
possession ma carte sd qui accrédite ma
version et quand la police est arrivée
ou leur avis ils n'ont pas voulu la
récupérer alors on m'a donné notre jack
qui était une charte du théâtre mais tu
n'es pas la mienne ca qu ils ont
toujours leur possession en fait ils ont
fait un échange mais ça reste du vol
puisque ils ont ma carte sd mais kelly
pour revenir sur les mots forts qui on
est et séquestration j'ai fouillé un
petit peu partout sur internet pour
aller voir au maximum ce que je pouvais
trouver comme vidéo et à plusieurs
vidéos on vous voit avec des personnes
autour de vous qui vous dites mais vous
n'êtes pas séquestrés monsieur regarder
la porte est ouverte allez-y oui c'est
vrai donc est-ce que vous en dire deux
camps nous on voit ça on a envie de vous
dire bah écoutez ce monsieur et sortait
mais on vous voit rester stoïque moi ce
qui m'étonne c'est que vous ayez reçu
cette vidéo il vous avez pas retenu
celle où j'ai toujours tenu mais
justement ça ça vous ne citez pas l'âge
où on entend finir la phrase je dis je
ne peux pas sortir on entend prononcer
le mot sortir et le fameux me répond
c'est normal vu ce que vous avez fait
certes cette femme du public de yassine
belattar considère qu'il est normal de
retenir un journaliste pour retirer pour
toute illégalité des vidéos de lui en
tout cas autant de gens là j'ai réalisé
légalement c'est pas admissible à ce
qu'on voit c'est très pratique et très
losique et la logique est ce que j'ai vu
et du coup quand la personne vous a dit
ça vous n'avez pas possibilité du tout
c'est là ma difficulté de vous prouver
ma version c'est plutôt que je n'ai pas
les images de la caméra de
vidéosurveillance yassine belattar
m'empêche de sortir j'espère dans
l'enregistrement avec les policiers du
xviiie on entendra dire je ne peux pas
sortir me retiens je n'ai pas de singer
alors dernière question celle d'après
accueillir les cibler non non tout à
l'heure vous de poser la question est ce
que c'est un article à charge je vous
dis pas spécialement pourquoi ne pas
avoir annoncé à l'équipe de yassine
belattar votre présence à ce spectacle
sans avoir annoncé ma présence je me
fait séquestrer imaginez si j'avais à me
voir et
vous ne serez peut-être pas allez vous
répondez à côté des questions de toutes
celles qu'on vous pose depuis le début
de la
compétition il ya une chose sur lequel
on peut pas m'accuser c'est de répondre
à votre question est vraiment rassuré
en eau souple et tranquille jusqu'à vous
savez que vous ne vous n'avez pas
demandé parce que vous savez que vous
n'aurez vous auriez bien évidemment mais
se disent lui s'est demandé à avoir un
patron est ce que quotidien demande
quand ils viennent à des meetings mais
c'est
juste jordan c'est ça c'est ça qui pose
problème actuellement et il ya des gens
qui disent on n'a pas envie de leur
parler donc s'ils viennent un moment ils
sont assez insistant et parfois on une
fois deux fois trois fois et c'est vrai
que c'est ça qui fait que ça monte un
petit peu dans les tours parfois il faut
faire attention parce que un moment il
va avoir des drames avec cette affaire
et c'est vrai que quand on dit non c'est
non voilà quand il quelqu'un vient avec
une caméra et un micro qu'on lui dit non
c'est non répond pas de gentiment à la
sortie non non
non non non il ya des journalistes qui
insiste énormément on va pas se mentir
arrêtez arrêtez de faire la moue truche
là dessus mais moi
il ya là les hommes et ils vous lâche
pas moi ça m'est pas arrivé voilà mais
si ça m'arrive
ça me
passe la soirée à parler de quelque
chose c'est vrai qu'on vient tuer par la
justice et la police a serait ma
crédibilité plus tôt tu te s'étonner du
fait qu'aucune société john isner mais
défendu un surplus minader descendrai
j'ai peint mais ça à la personne joue
maintenant il faut vous dire la vérité
là dessus je pense que tout le monde va
réagir le premier tient c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les gens et plein de gens
assez importants ont réagi sur plein
d'affaires à chaud et ça et ils ont vu
qu'ils étaient complètement à côté de la
plaque donc là mon avis ils attendent de
voir un petit peu ce qui se passe un
petit peu quels sont les deux versions
quelle est la version qui est a priori
de la version véridique ils attendent un
petit peu le rapport de police ne voit
un petit peu ce qui est dit par la
police et après je pense qu'ils vont
réagir là je pense que là dessus c'est
ça même si ta lumière d'encre par
plaisir mais parce que voulait peut-être
revoir le spectacle
voilà mais j'invite en toute hâte
d'autres journalistes et peut-être des
manques du ministère de l'intérieur à
des voix m'a très bien et bat jordan en
tout cas nous avons merci d'être venu
nous donner votre version ce soir merci
à vous de m'avoir nommé merci non mais
c'est important pour nous de l'avoir en
plus je le dis et
quoi je suis courageux la part de
domaine parce qu'il sait que yacine il
fait partie de l'équipe voilà on va pas
se mentir il fait partie dès qu'il fait
partie de la famille 21 pmp on lit et
donc bravo à vous d'être venu non mais
franchement merci merci et jordan et où
savez nous on est vraiment on essayait
d'être impartiaux vraiment complètement
et on voulait avoir votre version ce
soir sachez que ça nous fait pas plaisir
cette affaire que vous voilà si votre
histoire est vraie elle nous fait pas
plaisir même si je lis et je ne
digérerai jamais beaucoup yasin c c'est
un pote vraiment et ça me fait pas
plaisir mais je voulais votre version ce
soir j'étais important de la voir et
voilà moi j'aurais préféré que vous
disiez j'ai passé une excellente soirée
je suis rentré chez moi j'ai vu le
spectacle est après tout c'est bien
passé voilà donc ça
samassa maps et me voilà en tout cas
merci j'espère que j'aurai l'occasion
d'en passer encore de sérieux parce que
j'espère aussi qu'ils arrivent
maintenant j'en doute j'espère aussi
d'aller voir le spectacle de jean luc
lemoine qui est très bien aussi
merci merci je passe un ami aussi